Générique
...
- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour.
Bienvenue dans "Parlement hebdo".
- Kathia Gilder:
Nous accueillons Naïma Moutchou.
Merci d'être sur notre plateau.
Vous êtes députée
Horizons du Val-d'Oise
et vice-présidente
de l'Assemblée.
Cette semaine,
on va parler du projet
de loi immigration,
qui va être débattu
dès lundi au Sénat.
Gérald Darmanin
n'a pas trouvé d'accord
avec la majorité
de droite sénatoriale.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le droit à l'avortement
va être inscrit
dans la Constitution.
Emmanuel Macron
a annoncé un projet
de loi constitutionnelle
pour protéger
la liberté des femmes à recourir
à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse.
- Kathia Gilder:
Elisabeth Borne continue
de dégainer les 49.3
pour faire adopter
le budget de la Sécurité
sociale, faute
de majorité sur ce texte.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Les sénateurs
vont débuter ce lundi
l'examen du projet
de loi immigration.
L'article 3 sur la régulation
des travailleurs sans-papiers
dans les métiers en tension
pourrait faire échouer l'adoption
de ce texte au Sénat.
- L'hypothèse d'un accord
entre droite sénatoriale
et gouvernement
semble être au point mort.
Au coeur des dissensions,
l'article 3
qui prévoit la régularisation
des travailleurs étrangers
dans les métiers en tension.
- Je veux que le fait
de travailler
ne donne pas droit
à régularisation.
Vous pouvez
avoir des islamistes
qui travaillent.
Je veux
que le préfet puisse
se dire:
"Ca se passe bien,
mais en même temps,
est-ce qu'il est intégrable?"
- Les Républicains ont lancé
une pétition sur l'immigration,
mais pas question de lâcher du lest
sur l'article 3,
pour le ministre
de l'Intérieur.
- Il faut faire
la différence
entre l'étranger
qui veut s'intégrer
et qui respecte
nos règles,
et celui qui ne respecte pas
nos règles.
- Sans les voix des centristes,
les sénateurs LR
n'auront pas de majorité
pour supprimer l'article 3.
Or les centristes acceptent
seulement de le modifier.
Ils craignent que le texte ne puisse
pas être voté s'il est trop durci.
- L'article 3,
les travailleurs en tension,
c'est un périmètre très restreint.
Le problème,
c'est de savoir si on veut
ou si on ne veut pas
que ce texte
soit voté.
- Les sénateurs
ont restreint les conditions
de regroupement familial.
Ils envisagent de transformer
l'aide médicale d'Etat
en aide médicale d'urgence
avec un panier de soins restreint.
D'autres amendements prévoient
de supprimer toute protection
contre une mesure d'expulsion
du territoire français.
La chambre haute examine le projet
de loi jusqu'au 10 novembre.
- Alexandre Poussart:
La mesure divise
dans ce projet de loi
immigration, notamment
avec l'article 3
de régularisation
des travailleurs
sans-papiers
dans les métiers en tension.
Cette mesure
ne fait pas l'unanimité
au sein de la majorité
présidentielle.
On a déclaré que cet article
encourageait l'immigration
clandestine.
Ca veut dire
que vous allez proposer
un amendement de suppression
de cet article?
- Naïma Moutchou:
C'est vrai, j'ai dit
et je redis que l'article 3
doit faire partie
de ces sujets qui doivent
être débattus
à l'Assemblée.
Il y a quelque chose d'important.
Il faut réaffirmer
que notre objectif
est de lutter
contre l'immigration irrégulière.
J'ai un problème
intellectuel à l'idée
de dire que se maintenir
sur le territoire
de manière illégale
ouvrirait des droits.
C'est une problématique
qui est plutôt partagée,
y compris auprès
de mes collègues sénateurs.
C'est d'autant plus vrai
que la rédaction actuelle
de cet article
indique
que plus vous vous maintenez
illégalement
sur le territoire,
plus vous avez des chances
d'être régularisé.
Notre priorité,
ça doit être la lutte
contre le trafic
de main-d'oeuvre
et les patrons voyous.
Le travail illégal,
c'est une économie d'exploitation
qui a des conséquences
très graves
en matière de tension sociale,
d'économie souterraine.
En même temps,
je vois le pays réel.
Je vois ce qui se passe
dans la société.
Il y a des travailleurs
irréguliers
et il faut se poser
la question
de ce qui se passe,
de ce qu'on peut faire,
car les éloigner
alors qu'ils seraient intégrés,
ce n'est pas
non plus une solution.
La régularisation
automatique,
c'est un problème.
Regarder au cas par cas,
ce serait davantage faire preuve
de justice.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il faut supprimer l'article 3?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je veux redire
que cet article 3
ne peut pas être un chiffon rouge
ou un totem de ma part.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous êtes prête à voter
le texte tel quel?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je veux faire
mon travail
de parlementaire et faire
une proposition pour une rédaction
éventuelle nouvelle
de cet article 3.
Le ministre
de l'Intérieur a tendu
la main sur ce sujet
en disant
que les parlementaires
pouvaient proposer
et améliorer ce texte.
Je crois
que la régularisation au cas
par cas est la solution
qui doit être envisagée.
- Kathia Gilder:
Cela existe déjà
avec la circulaire Valls.
Qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
comme amélioration?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Il faut voir
si nous avons la capacité
aujourd'hui
de transposer dans la loi
cette régularisation
au cas par cas.
En tant que législateurs,
pouvons-nous réécrire
dans la loi cette circulaire?
- Alexandre Poussart:
Si cet article
n'est pas amélioré
dans sa rédaction,
vous le voterez quand même?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Ce texte est indispensable.
Il n'est pas suffisant.
Le défi migratoire est immense.
Ce qui arrive
devant nous ne peut
pas être réglé comme ça.
Le texte est insuffisant.
Quand vous regardez
ce qui se passe,
les mouvements de population
dans le monde,
les guerres, la misère,
la corruption,
le réchauffement climatique...
Il va y avoir des mouvements
importants
vers l'Europe.
Un seul texte de loi
ne peut pas répondre
au défi migratoire.
Mais ce texte
est nécessaire,
parce qu'il apporte des réponses.
- Kathia Gilder:
Est-ce que votre avis
est partagé par les autres
membres d'Horizons?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Ce sont des débats
que nous allons avoir.
Au sein du groupe
Horizons,
on a une expression libre.
- Kathia Gilder:
Donc c'est votre position?
- Naïma Moutchou: Oui.
J'en ai parlé
avec mes collègues,
et on se retrouve
autour de la nécessité
de parler de cet article 3.
Nous considérons
que c'est un texte ambitieux
parce qu'il propose
de raccourcir
les délais, de simplifier
les procédures
et de mieux lutter contre ceux
qui troublent l'ordre public.
- Kathia Gilder:
Un collectif de parlementaires
va proposer des amendements
communs, notamment
pour conserver
cette régularisation
des travailleurs sans-papiers.
Est-ce que ça veut dire
que la majorité peut
se fracturer sur ce texte?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Ce qui est sûr,
c'est qu'il faut
avoir des débats de fond.
Il faut que nous puissions
débattre
sur ce texte
et que nous ne fassions
pas ce qui arrive
traditionnellement
quand on parle d'immigration:
s'enfermer dans des postures
et des slogans.
S'il y a un travail de réécriture,
y compris de l'aile gauche
de la majorité
ou de groupes de la NUPES,
c'est intéressant.
Nous irons au vote
en confrontant les opinions.
J'appelle de mes voeux
cet exercice,
qui est un exercice du Parlement.
Je demande que nous sortions
d'un certain nombre de clichés
et de caricatures sur le sujet.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Quel autre durcissement
du projet
de loi immigration souhaitez-vous?
Souhaitez-vous durcir
l'aide médicale d'Etat
pour la transformer
en aide médicale d'urgence?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je préfère parler d'amélioration
que de durcissement.
Evidemment
qu'il y a la question
de l'aide médicale d'Etat.
Ce sujet est récurrent.
Il est permanent.
C'est sain de s'interroger
sur ces sujets.
La question du panier de soins...
Il ne s'agit pas
de supprimer l'accès
aux soins aux travailleurs
en situation irrégulière.
D'abord, pour des questions
d'humanisme,
de manière très triviale,
et par ailleurs,
il y a des questions
de santé publique
qui se posent.
En revanche,
notre responsabilité
est de regarder
de plus près pour voir
si le système peut
être amélioré,
en restreignant
l'accès aux soins
à des soins indispensables.
- Kathia Gilder:
Sur l'immigration,
est-ce que vous assumez
d'être plus proche
d'un député LR
que d'un député Renaissance?
Vous souhaitez durcir
certaines mesures.
- Naïma Moutchou:
J'assume de dire
ce que je crois,
ce que je crois
être le meilleur
pour l'intérêt général.
Je ne me positionne pas
par rapport
à untel ou untel.
Je dis simplement
qu'il faut regarder
ce qui se passe,
nous le devons
aux Français.
Vous savez combien
nos compatriotes
sont inquiets sur les sujets
de l'immigration.
Il faut être en capacité
de faire
les constats qui s'imposent,
de dépasser
les non-dits sur le sujet
et de proposer
ce qui nous paraît
être le plus adéquat.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Vous défendez l'essentiel
de ce texte.
On n'a pas de majorité
sur ce projet
de loi à l'Assemblée.
Si ça reste le cas,
faudra-t-il passer
par un 49.3 pour faire
adopter ce texte?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je ne sais pas
si c'est le scénario
qui est envisagé.
Les sénateurs
vont bientôt examiner
en séance publique ce texte.
Ensuite, ce sera
à l'Assemblée nationale
de participer au débat.
Nous verrons ce qui en ressortira.
Pour l'instant,
il faut se donner
toutes les chances
d'aller au bout
et d'aller au vote,
y compris s'il s'agit
de mettre
devant leurs responsabilités
chacun des groupes d'opposition.
C'est un débat trop important
pour qu'il soit escamoté.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les Républicains menacent
de déposer une motion de censure.
Ce serait une première
pour ce groupe
dans le quinquennat.
Les oppositions
auraient alors le moyen
de faire tomber le gouvernement.
Vous croyez que ce scénario
est possible?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Tout est possible.
Ce ne serait pas
la première motion de censure.
Il y en a eu quelques-unes, déjà.
Elle pourrait aboutir,
parce que la nouveauté,
ce serait que Les Républicains
seraient à la manoeuvre,
mais j'ai entendu
le groupe socialiste
indiquer qu'il ne voterait pas
la motion en question.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Donc pour vous, il n'y a pas
de motion de censure adoptée
dans ce quinquennat
si les oppositions
ne sont pas unies?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je n'ai pas de boule de cristal.
En tout cas, elles ne sont pas
en capacité aujourd'hui
de former
une majorité alternative.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va continuer
avec cette liberté
des femmes à recourir
à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse,
qui serait gravée
dans la Constitution
pour la rendre
irréversible en 2024.
C'est l'annonce d'Emmanuel Macron.
Le texte est entre les mains
du Conseil d'Etat,
en vue d'une présentation
en Conseil des ministres
d'ici la fin de l'année.
- C'est sur le réseau social X,
anciennement Twitter,
qu'Emmanuel Macron
a confirmé: "En 2024,
la liberté des femmes à recourir
à l'IVG sera irréversible."
Le gouvernement
dépose un projet
de loi constitutionnelle
pour l'inscrire à l'article 34.
- Si ce droit est défendu
sur la quasi-totalité
des bancs de cet hémicycle,
nous avons un devoir de vigilance.
La décision de la Cour suprême
des Etats-Unis l'année dernière
a rappelé que le droit
à l'avortement pouvait
être menacé, même
dans une grande démocratie.
Jusque sur notre continent,
plusieurs partis d'extrême droite
veulent remettre en cause
cette liberté fondamentale
pour les femmes.
- Les insoumis,
qui avaient fait adopter
en novembre dernier
une proposition de loi
pour constitutionnaliser
l'IVG,
se disent prêts
à voter le texte
et en accepter la rédaction,
même si, eux,
préfèrent le mot "droit"
à celui de "liberté".
- Je suis attachée
au fait qu'on réindique
que le droit à l'avortement
est un droit fondamental humain.
Ce n'est pas ma formulation,
mais je la voterai.
- La droite est moins convaincue.
- Le président de la République
a un drôle de sens des priorités
et du tempo.
L'IVG ne me semble pas être
la priorité du moment.
Personne n'a remis en cause
l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse en France
au Parlement.
- Un projet de loi
ouvre la voie
à une adoption l'année prochaine
par le Congrès,
la réunion des députés
et sénateurs.
- Kathia Gilder: Le choix des mots
est important.
Telle que la rédaction se présente,
il y aura les mots
"liberté des femmes
à recourir à l'IVG"
plutôt que "droit des femmes".
Est-ce que cette rédaction
vous convient?
- Naïma Moutchou: C'est un débat
que nous aurons prochainement.
Le président
de la République a indiqué
que ce projet de loi
serait examiné en 2024.
Je ne sais pas
si c'est une avancée.
Je considère
et je constate
que les responsables
politiques en France
ne remettent pas en cause
le droit à l'IVG.
- Kathia Gilder: Il faut l'inscrire
dans la Constitution?
- Naïma Moutchou: C'est éminemment
symbolique pour les femmes.
Dans un contexte
de tension
et dans un contexte
où le lien social
est remis en cause,
même si je n'aime pas importer
les débats outre-Atlantique,
c'est vrai que ce serait
un symbole puissant
de l'inscrire demain
dans la Constitution.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On va revenir
sur l'utilité de cette révision
constitutionnelle.
Vous préférez "droit" ou "liberté"
des femmes à recourir à l'IVG?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Ca ne dit pas la même chose.
- Kathia Gilder:
Un droit est opposable
devant un juge.
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je veux laisser
la place au débat.
Je n'ai pas d'opinion aujourd'hui.
Je considère
qu'on ne modifie pas
la Constitution d'un coup de crayon
fait la main tremblante.
Ce sont des débats très sérieux.
Il faut savoir
quelles sont les conséquences
de chacun de ces termes,
la capacité
ou pas pour le législateur
d'intervenir.
La question est celle
de la sécurité de l'IVG.
Est-ce qu'un terme apporte
plus de sécurité
ou pas que l'autre?
La raison pour laquelle
on veut inscrire l'IVG
dans la Constitution,
c'est bien
pour qu'il ne soit
plus jamais remis en cause.
- Kathia Gilder: Il l'est,
pour vous, en France?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je n'ai pas entendu
de responsables
politiques remettre
en cause ce droit
à l'IVG, heureusement.
Encore une fois,
quand on fait
de la politique,
quand on fait la loi,
il y a aussi
des symboles très forts
qui doivent être inscrits,
pourquoi pas,
dans la Constitution.
- Alexandre Poussart:
C'est une portée symbolique,
quand des parlementaires
comme Bruno Retailleau
ou Marine Le Pen disent
que cette révision
constitutionnelle est inutile?
Le droit à l'avortement
est déjà protégé
par la loi Veil en France.
On est simplement dans le symbole?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Le symbole n'est jamais inutile.
Tous ces principes inscrits
dans la Constitution
seraient alors inutiles.
Ce n'est pas comme ça
que je réfléchis.
C'est un sujet
important, un sujet
de société qui est important.
Parfois, l'inscrire
dans le marbre,
c'est un message
puissant qu'on envoie
à la population.
- Kathia Gilder:
Pour qu'il soit adopté,
ce texte doit l'être
dans les mêmes termes
par les deux chambres.
Est-ce que vous craignez
que la majorité sénatoriale
de droite le fasse échouer?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Aurait-elle intérêt à le faire?
A moins que les sénateurs
souhaitent diviser
sur cette question...
Nous verrons.
Ca leur appartient.
- Alexandre Poussart:
En cas d'échec
de cette inscription
dans la Constitution,
est-ce qu'il faudra passer
par un référendum?
- Naïma Moutchou:
C'est une possibilité
qui appartient au président
de la République.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Peut-être un mot
sur le calendrier
de cette annonce.
Est-ce que c'est la priorité
du moment,
pour reprendre les mots
d'Olivier Marleix,
alors qu'on parle
beaucoup d'immigration
et de sécurité? Est-ce que
ce n'est pas une diversion?
- Naïma Moutchou: Je ne crois pas.
Je ne rentre pas
dans ces considérations
qui sont, pour moi, de niveau
de débat politique politicien.
Ce n'est jamais
le moment pour rien.
Le contexte
est difficile,
vous avez raison,
mais nous ne sommes pas à côté
de ces sujets-là.
Il y a un texte
sur l'immigration
qui va être présenté.
Il y a également
le projet de loi de finances.
Il y a des choses qui sont faites.
A côté de ça,
il y a d'autres thématiques.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous craignez un retour
de la mobilisation
des mouvements pro-vie
qu'on avait pu
voir pour empêcher
cette inscription de l'IVG
dans la Constitution?
- Naïma Moutchou:
C'est un risque,
oui, parce que ce sont des débats
abrasifs pour la société.
Ce sont des sujets
qui réveillent
des clivages sociétaux,
tout comme pour la fin de vie.
C'est un sujet
qui pourrait venir
en débat à l'Assemblée nationale.
Je n'ai pas plus de précisions
sur le calendrier.
Effectivement,
c'est un risque.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Avec ces débats sociétaux,
vous ne craignez pas
que la cohésion sociale
en France
ne soit encore plus abîmée
par le fait de mettre ces débats
sur la table?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Nous devons être vigilants,
c'est vrai. Nous devrons
faire preuve de pédagogie.
Il faudra prendre
les moyens d'expliquer
ce qui est fait,
pourquoi c'est fait.
- Kathia Gilder:
Notamment sur la fin
de vie.
Vous souhaitez
qu'il y ait un débat,
que ce texte
soit inscrit à l'ordre du jour?
- Naïma Moutchou:
C'est un sujet important.
Je ne suis pas favorable
à ce qu'il vienne immédiatement.
Je ne crois pas que le sujet
soit suffisamment mûr, aujourd'hui.
Il y a des étapes
à franchir avant d'évoquer
ce sujet, y compris
dans le débat public,
par le Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder:
Dans la nuit de lundi
à mardi, à l'Assemblée nationale,
Elisabeth Borne
a déclenché une fois
de plus l'article 49.3
pour faire passer
sans vote le texte
du budget 2024
de la Sécurité sociale.
C'est la 15e fois
qu'elle a recours à cette arme.
- Pour ce projet
de loi de financement
de la Sécurité sociale,
comme pour tous les textes
depuis un an et demi,
les ministres ont mené
des concertations
et nous avons tendu la main
aux oppositions.
Cependant, malgré notre volonté
de dialogue,
aucun groupe d'opposition
n'a souhaité dévier
de sa ligne.
Nous devons protéger
notre modèle social
et améliorer le quotidien
de nos concitoyens.
Aussi, sur le fondement
de l'article 49.3
de la Constitution,
j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement
sur la troisième partie
et l'ensemble du projet
de loi de financement
de la Sécurité sociale pour 2024.
Je vous remercie.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les motions de censure
succèdent aux 49.3
à l'Assemblée,
écourtant les discussions.
Est-ce que le débat budgétaire
a encore un sens
dans ces conditions?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Le déclenchement du 49.3,
ce n'est jamais quelque chose
de très agréable
ou de satisfaisant
pour un parlementaire.
Le coeur de métier de député
ou du sénateur, c'est le débat.
C'est d'aller au vote pour exprimer
une position politique.
Je suis attachée au débat.
Le gouvernement n'a pas le choix.
C'est même une question
de responsabilité
pour l'exécutif.
Sinon, quoi?
Un pays sans budget,
sans loi de finances?
Les oppositions ont dit
qu'elles refusaient
de voter le budget.
Je constate
que ceux qui se plaignent
aujourd'hui de l'utilisation
du 49.3, voire
qui en demandent
la suppression,
c'est eux qui ont utilisé
le 49.3,
comme sur la loi CPE
sous le gouvernement Villepin
ou la loi El Khomri
sous le gouvernement Valls.
Il y a nécessité.
Il faut se rappeler
l'esprit des fondateurs
de la Constitution
et de cet article 49.3.
C'est un moyen de débloquer
les situations.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le gouvernement
n'a pas le choix,
selon vous,
mais le gouvernement
a le choix de laisser
le débat parlementaire
aller à son terme.
Il a le choix de voir
quels amendements pourraient
être retenus.
Avec le 49.3,
il n'y a même plus cette volonté
de laisser le débat.
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je constate que l'année dernière,
quand on a laissé
le débat se faire,
les oppositions
s'en sont plaintes,
estimant que les débats
étaient galvaudés
et que c'était
un simulacre de débat.
Quand le gouvernement
décide d'aller plus vite,
les oppositions
ne sont toujours pas satisfaites.
Je m'interroge.
Les débats ont lieu
en commission,
c'est important de le dire.
Ensuite, il y a une question
de responsabilité.
Si nous démarrons les débats
et que pleuvent les amendements
et les milliards
pour les dépenses publiques,
c'est une problématique.
Donc la responsabilité l'emporte.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous dites
qu'il y a eu un débat
en commission
des finances,
c'est vrai, notamment
sur un sujet très sensible:
la taxation
des superdividendes.
Une partie de la majorité
souhaitait qu'il y ait une taxe,
et elle n'aura pas lieu.
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je trouve le débat intéressant.
Je fais partie
de ceux qui étaient favorables
à la taxation des superprofits.
Les superdividendes,
c'est autre chose.
L'intérêt de ce débat,
c'est de mettre
dans la question publique
comment on peut mieux répartir
les richesses.
Cela participe
à la justice sociale.
Je suis toujours
ouverte à ce débat.
Je m'interroge
sur les conséquences
en termes financiers,
en termes de liberté
d'entreprendre
pour un certain nombre de sociétés.
Les dividendes,
c'est censé être le fruit
redistribué aux actionnaires.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le gouvernement n'a pas entendu
cette demande de taxer
les superprofits.
- Alexandre Poussart: La majorité
présidentielle le demande.
- Naïma Moutchou:
Ca n'a pas été accepté,
ni par le gouvernement, ni...
Alors, par une partie
de la majorité.
Je suis persuadée
que le débat reviendra,
peut-être sous une autre forme,
mais ce n'est jamais inintéressant.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez?
Vous souhaitez qu'on demande
plus d'efforts
aux plus aisés
dans cette période d'inflation?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je crois
que c'est important,
oui, cet effort
de solidarité nationale.
Sur les superprofits,
je trouve
que ce n'était pas
déraisonnable
de considérer
que quand une entreprise
dégageait des bénéfices
sans avoir rien fait,
c'est-à-dire
simplement bénéficiait
de la crise, de dire
qu'elle pouvait participer,
à un certain niveau,
à cette redistribution
au profit
de ceux qui en avaient
le plus besoin, compte
tenu des difficultés
que certaines familles
rencontraient.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous présidez
une partie de ces séances.
Est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire
quelle est l'ambiance en séance?
Est-ce que vous pensez
que l'Assemblée nationale peut
tenir dans ces conditions,
entre motions
de censure et 49.3,
jusqu'à 2027?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Elle a tenu jusqu'ici.
La configuration
de l'Assemblée nationale
nous contraint à aller,
texte par texte,
rechercher les majorités.
Ca demande beaucoup
d'énergie,
mais je pense
que c'est une méthode
de travail plutôt saine.
C'est important,
d'engager le dialogue
avec l'opposition.
Il faut avoir cette culture
de travail.
C'est vrai que les débats
sont dynamiques.
Moi qui préside
ces séances publiques,
je le sens,
du haut du perchoir,
mais en même temps,
c'est important
que les groupes
politiques,
ils sont 10,
puissent s'exprimer.
C'est important que les gens
se sentent représentés.
Des débats tendus,
il y en a toujours eu, en réalité.
Cette vie à l'Assemblée nationale,
c'est important
que les Français le ressentent.
- Kathia Gilder: Merci.
Ce sera le mot de la fin.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Merci à tous de nous avoir suivis.